so I'm sitting here with my brother
business partner and also CEO over the
Samuel age group and one of the things
that he does is he has a high chair own
management company a lot of HMOs
personally we also have HMOs that we own
individually and through the company and
today we're gonna be talking about our
HMOs ruining the country so why don't
you kick off Russell our HMOs as report
to both Sun and a lot of HMO critics say
that they run in the country there's
been articles written about it what are
you thoughts no so that's the end of the
video see you next week thank you so
much for watching if you benefited from
that video please do share it with your
family and friends okay so why don't you
tell me why people say hey tumors are
ruining okay it's obvious the newspapers
about it yeah I've read them that their
reason is because they say that it kills
community neighbors a lot of neighbors
have complained about there being houses
in streets like a whole street filled
with yeah rooms the street I know Joe
that it kills community how can you have
you know like a village and a church and
if people look on they're just renting a
room for six twelve months and then
moving on you know it really kills it
really kills to me because I think
that's the first reason so I mean just
say about that well I would say in that
there are people but there's a market
for and there is a marketplace because
there are people that want to live in a
room or a party how is it different from
an apartment to apartment skill
community because apartments you have
your own living space you have your own
kitchen your own bath how exactly
community though Wow well you tend to
stay longer so if you're in an apartment
you might stay there five ten years your
first house that you bought yeah what
was it
there's an apartment there's an
apartment what's the lady's name today
Denise you bought the apartment we've
Deniz living there yeah you bought the
apartment what like 10 years ago
yeah what's the tenants name now did
alright so Denise's lived there two
years have you got a HMO where the
tenant has lived
ten years I oven for I have four years
five liters about the max but usually
they'll stay for six twelve months so it
so your reason is is because of my
reason this is what they're saying but
okay there there is is is because people
are moving house too much yeah and also
would you like to live next door to a
house that was HMO yourself I wouldn't
care you would get you you you you you
would get you I had a problem you could
well that's I guess that's a whole new
level I won't embarrass you but you told
me am I allowed to say no you've got a
beautiful Tudor house yeah it's a
beautiful area but you told me that
there was too many average houses in the
area by and by average you mean 300
thousand pound houses and by in the area
you mean within half a mile so you would
mind living next to HM our house no I
wouldn't I don't my next day you would I
wouldn't mind living a stage of my
tenants you may be like a right dick now
so families I've got kids wanna be in
next are you going behind and me buying
all these hm our houses all we just kill
in the community are we ruining the
country that's their argument
yeah so what do you say I would say oh
you see what that can you see where
they're coming from
oh I genuinely wouldn't mind living next
to H mobile okay as long as it's the
house look nice
I mean obviously you know I want to be
like a nice area but I wouldn't mind
people move in and coming and going yeah
that wouldn't bother me at all as long
as they weren't like being loud and
destructive and stuff like that yeah I
suppose there's a market for it so where
where else are these people what what so
what they're not allowed to live I just
I just don't understand how it's ruining
the country like if you could give me
examples Oh like in an area of those
HMOs the crime rate sheets are through
the roof or or something like that I
could go okay I don't think it does that
I don't think it does I don't understand
I can't see I can't see why it would
make a difference I can't see why it's
an issue
at all and I guess hey chairs are in
particular types of areas and particular
types of streets so when we're buying
HMOs we're not buying them in nice
family villages so but we're buying
going to miss city centers where there's
apartments and shops and things anyone
you bought you're buying them we're well
city centers we buying them yeah really
or close by sometimes they're all
families next door yeah yeah of course
the families ever but their apartments
everywhere there were studio apartments
everywhere how is a Haitian elephant
from a studio apartment really yeah I
know the slightly different in the
interior in the you know in studio part
when you got your own bathroom for
example although in some homos you do a
slightly different kind of topic I think
as well that these the same type of
people that say HMOs are ruling the
country don't like the idea
they're already annoyed with landlords
buying loads of houses yeah because they
feel that when their landlord buys a lot
of houses they're taken away from
first-time buyers and they're just
dominating a street they don't like that
but it makes it even worse when you
change the use of house it's a it's a
HMO property you've got all these houses
and you're running them like rabbit runs
potentially and it just you know it's
just taking away like rabbit runs
obviously when we talked about this a
little bit on the on the compliance
video you don't you don't want anyone to
be running them like rabbit runs you
want to be a professional nice yeah
affordable accommodation and you're
servicing a need like I know that HMOs
have become very popular recently but
you a student net so they ruin in the
country I think here's the thing people
that say it's ruin in the country it's
forget that the only reason that we're
doing it in the first place is because
there's a need for it that's the thing
what we're doing is we're seeing
actually seeing a gap in the market and
then stepping into that gap there's
people that need rooms the can't afford
an apartment and then the bills and this
and that the other so we're giving them
convenience we're given them we're
giving the country exactly what the
country wants so here's a question that
if there wasn't a HMOs would there be
more people on the streets
maybe maybe although I don't think the
type of people that live in our actual
eyes will be like
to be on the streets no but let's say
there what if there wasn't a mock if
there wasn't basically HMOs really he's
an affordability level that is below
yeah they'd probably be a lot more
people in debt because people that maybe
are struggling for money or trying to
save up to people that want to people
that are struggling with debt or people
are wanting to save up to buy their own
house and be a first-time buyer yeah
we're helping them do that there'll be
people still living with her parents
still living at home which happens
against as well oh yeah loads people are
still living at home when he's like so
actually we're helping people get out of
debt by giving them an affordable living
yeah
we're helping them be in a position
where they can save because the average
wage for a young person that gets their
first job is about grand a month and the
average rent for it for it for a very
basic average is about six hundred
pounds a month and then you got your
bills so how can you be hacked you've
got no money left over you how can you
afford to live so we're helping them not
only live but also in a position where
they can save so that they can then
afford to be a first car buyer yeah I
would love the people that said that
hates roads were in the country I'd love
to see some stats about that oh yeah
like what the only thing they've got is
neighbors are moaning and yeah greedy
landlords do moan one of our landlords
recently bought a property and when the
neighbors found out that it was going to
be turned into HMO and the builders
turned up they attack them physically
physically attack what if your investors
yeah Wow physically attack them the
neighbors did they went around threaten
them first and then physically attacked
them and the builders of film some of it
until the phone got smashed out their
hand on the floor police got involved
with everything Wow that's not normal
that no neighbors that our neighbors
don't usually moan what would British
neighbors usually touch don't know if
they've got a problem so some people are
outraged at the HMOs being being how's
it been turning to HMOs mmm-hmm yeah but
all they've ruin in the country no
because also if it's an area where it
where a HMO is not wanted and hmm walk
will not work we wouldn't buy it there
anyway we're only buying HMOs where
people are looking for rooms anyway so
they weren't renting
if they'd only event someone else's
rooms or that only rent a studio tonight
I've noticed I've noticed some HMOs in
in different areas that as well now so
you know long long de near where I live
yeah lovely little very posh high-end
village there's HMO there what I think
it's targeting my single people double
staying staying staying the nice area
but yeah yeah fully lat
you're not gonna have streets filled
with those no but the odd one that could
work really nicely mm-hmm
so the conclusion is HMOs are not
ruining the country and we're just
seeing a gap stepping in and if it's
over saturated we'll stop buying its the
council put article four in will stop
doing it yeah what it's supply and
demand isn't it yeah people are always
gonna also be interested to see the
people that are moaning about HMOs being
oversaturated what are they doing to
solve the problem probably just moaning
about it
probably just moaning I was saying if
you can change it change it if you can't
shut up so I didn't invent the rules I
just follow them next video is gonna be
about do HMOs work up north well so
you've got some very interesting
thoughts to say about that well we've
invested heavily up north so yeah it got
a lot of input on that so do HMOs work
up north what kind of returns can you
expect to get if you'd like to check out
that video it should be on the screen
right now like subscribe share see you
next time
thank you so much for watching if you
benefited from that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time